Oh air
air
Once I get out
of here I want to be with you forever Then I'll be with you
[music]
Uh why did I cry
?
Maybe I was happy In a
world as beautiful as a picture book I thought
I could become this person
But this world didn't allow me to
do that I wonder why why why I ca
n't find the answer
I wonder if it's because I'm just a child who doesn't have the power to protect anyone
How come I didn't notice
Me and him are
different creatures with different colored blood and
I was a monster
[music]
me when I was a child
Even if it's dangerous for how many years, you
'll die That's why I swore I
'll use my hands to become a human being If I become the
same as him
, I shouldn't be able to be with him
forever.  - To put it simply,
[music]
That's right,
because I'm a
picture book
person.